the baltimore defensive coordinator wink
martindale wink martindale
yeah don martin yes wink that's my boy
he said
he said he said that uh patrick mahomes
is
under paid do you buy that mahomes
who's got a huge contract uh the biggest
contract in football
do you think he's underpaid uh yeah
yeah i do i do because listen obviously
not
literally but i think wink's point is
you can't pay a guy like that enough
you can't pay somebody like that enough
money and i get i get why he says that
because you think about how he affects
not just
the offense but the entire team not and
not just the team's construction
but the overall effectiveness and
functioning of the team he makes
everybody's job on his side easier
everybody's job on the other side harder
uh he affects legacies he affects bottom
lines he affects the league
i mean look if if you want to really get
deep on it
let's get deep roger goodell roger
goodell was moved in the off-season
he was moved in the offseason and that's
interesting because watson signed a
shorter deal let's just keep in mind my
home's deals for 10 years
um but nonetheless um roger goodell the
commissioner of the nfl
who last year said
our fans want players to stand for the
national anthem who acted on behalf of
the owners
when it came to suppressing
player quote unquote protests during the
national anthem
right he was moved to say to proclaim
that black lives matter
in response to a video
that featured patrick mahomes and others
but the face of his league called him
out in that video
so that's just that's just on some next
level stuff in terms of his
impact but just as a player
whether it's your offensive line whether
it's your wide receivers whether it's
your running back whether it's how you
allocate resources on your roster if
you're andy reid
in that organization on the other side i
mean
how do you defend a dude that's every
every bit as capable as
converting a third and 25 with his arm
as he is his legs
you know um he has a but he has the
potential to be a transcendent performer
and we talked about it when he turned 25
years old he could end up going down
when it's all said and done when you
combine his the start that he's off to
his potential his talent uh his approach
his circumstances which is super
important
when you combine all of that he has the
potential to go down as the best ever
when it's all said and done and so yeah
i love yeah yeah
and obviously no lead is safe no lead is
safe when you're playing against them
yeah assets ask the networks hell ask
espn
ask the networks how much patrimo holmes
is worth putting him on in prime time
yeah he's that guy he's that guy you
know you want to see whatever he's doing
you want to know what patrick mahomes is
up to but now
i will say this look uh part of this
part of
a coordinator's job or a head coach's
job the smart ones
just blow kisses blow kisses at the
opponent
he's good at that so yeah i do that and
of course you say he's underpaid i pay
him anything he's
unbelievable but just to bring it back a
little bit
you look at all those numbers up there
we had that great chart of the top
contracts and of course
my home's at the top of the list but it
is a salary cap league
and right now is good right now okay
dude look at these names
a couple of them go oh boy not ryan they
probably could spend a little more money
on defense we'll talk about that later
um stafford wentz
derek carr i don't know but the salary
cap league
eventually you're gonna have to make
some tough decisions
about who you pay and so right now
they're defending super bowl champs and
you say oh good yeah pay patrick mahomes
anything eventually
you're gonna have to make some tough
decisions that's all i'll say that's
right
i don't mind equipment as far as you say
that all right let's flip in the
franchise mode then shall we let's go to
the front franchise mode because
franchise mode
okay cause a lot of people thank you a
lot of people like to say well
you know if you build a great team do
you have to have a great quarterback
and you know who asked themselves that
question you know who approached it oh
look at that look how we fancy with it
yeah yeah run that again
run that again oh well almost cuz
yeah that's what i'm talking about
that's what i'm talking about new
segment
who this oh listen
listen and i wouldn't even franchise
more with the cheese i would not
franchise more than she's cause it's too
easy
it's too easy he covers
covers up for a lot i'll make tough
decisions if i have to when it comes to
the cap
the penis what i was about to say the
people who ask themselves well do we
really need a special quarterback
or can we just that's the people that
don't have one that's people that don't
have one
i guarantee you the people trying to
build a team around a quarterback with
trade places with kansas city
because it makes your job that much
easier they trade places with
you know people say the same thing about
peyton manning back in the day all the
defense is suffering
this than the other like no they got
peyton manning i'll take that trade off
you understand what i'm saying like yes
you can if you have
obviously the quarterback needs a
supporting cast and i get the logic of
well hey if you're paying the
quarterback too much and your offensive
line ends up suffering or your defense
you can't keep you
your players that's all well and good
then you know what keep drafting keep
replenishing
that's a first world problem is what i'm
getting at so if i'm building a
franchise
and i'm and i and i can't find a patrick
mahomes
then yes the alternative is to do the
best you can at that position
yeah and support him that's great but if
i got patrick my homes i'm happy to pay
because you know what they say about
gm's
either you got a quarterback or you're
looking for one
oh and we'll talk about that today
because there are a lot of a lot of
situations on the table
where we got to talk about the
quarterback situation but i'll say this
i agree with you
i agree with you ultimately if you have
a franchise quarterback
there are worse places to be of course
you want to have one of the top
quarterbacks in football
but this is where we disagree it's hard
to franchise mode the chiefs
after winning the championship because
now you're starting to think
how long do i keep it going because what
you want to do is
is really what they did in the offseason
you think about what they did in the off
season they didn't just sign
patrick mahomes they ran it back
everybody got paid
from kansas city and that's what you do
when you win it and that's a very
sentimental usually a wrong-headed
move to make at some point you got to
say look we won super bowl
yeah we won the super bowl we got to
hold on to the holmes
but they paid everybody i mean they pay
they were all smart i mean they were
smart i mean you have to resign travis
kelsey you had to pay chris jones i mean
but
well-run organizations will ultimately
make tough decisions all i'm saying is
you got a guy like that
you have a chance every game and every
year you got a chance to be there at the
end you know the chiefs are going to be
a factor for as long as he's playing
simple input simply put no matter who is
around him
he's going to elevate them and they're
going to go deep into the playoffs i
don't know i mean i i'd like to think
that
like they should that think that about
patrick mahomes
no i don't think that about um no no
because history doesn't
support what you just said i mean that
doesn't happen with every great
quarterback every great quarterback is
not
contention going not really
mostly a great quarter most of the great
quarterbacks do not miss the playoffs
barring some you know unforeseen
circumstances most of the great
questions
they may not win the super bowl every
year they may not it may not be
everybody's birthright like it is tom
brady's
for the last few years to have been in a
conference championship game the way it
was in new england
but for the most part a great
quarterback like mahomes you're not
missing the playoffs you may not win but
you're not missing you're there
i guess and you can't put up i guess i
just i guess i just held on to
deep into the playoffs
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports